bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler de ces objets étranges et
mystérieux qu'on appelle les trous noirs
alors je voudrais vous expliquer déjà
qu'est ce que c'est ou est-ce qu'on en
trouve
et puis quelle est la bonne attitude à
avoir si jamais vous en croisez un les
trous noirs en boîte des objets très
complexe dont on n'a pas encore fini
d'élucider la structure aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous expliquer qu'on peut
comprendre leur existence grâce à un
simple petit calcul qui ne fait appel
qu'à de la physique de lycée alors
imaginons que vous soyez sur terre et
que vous lanciez une balle de tennis
enlève la balle va monter jusqu'à une
certaine hauteur et puis elle va
redescendre
si vous lancez la balle plus fort elle
va monter plus haut mais
vraisemblablement elle va quand même
finir par redescendre
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est à
quelle vitesse il faudrait lancer la
balle de tennis pour qu'elle ne retombe
jamais se dire qu'elle échappe à
l'attraction terrestre et bien comme
dans la vidéo que j'avais fait sur le
saut à la perche on peut arriver à
répondre à cette question en faisant un
simple calcul d'énergie quand on lance
une balle à une certaine vitesse on lui
donne une énergie qu'on appelle
l'énergie cinétique et qui est d'autant
plus grande que la vitesse est élevée
cette énergie cinétique elle va être
dépensé pour vaincre la force de gravité
qui retient la balle sur terre et à
laquelle on peut associer aussi une
énergie l'énergie gravitationnelle la
condition pour que la balle ne retombe
jamais et sa rage de l'attraction
terrestre c'est tout simplement que
l'énergie cinétique soit supérieure à
l'énergie gravitationnelle alors
évidemment il ya des équations pour
exprimer tout ça donc si on prend cette
équation et qu'on la tripote un peu on
peut en sortir que la vitesse minimum
que la balle doit posséder pour
s'arracher définitivement de
l'attraction terrestre ses racines de de
gm sur r si vous lancez la balle en
dessous de cette vitesse elle finira par
tomber
si vous la lancez au dessus de cette
vitesse elle partira dans l'espace et ne
retombera jamais cette vitesse minimum à
posséder pour s'arracher de l'attraction
terrestre
on l'appelle la vitesse de libération et
vous voyez qu'elle dépend de la masse de
la planète et de son rayon donc on peut
s'amuser à essayer calculer sa valeur
pour quelques astres bien connu par
exemple pour la terre cette vitesse de
libération elle vaut 11 km
monde c'est vraiment beaucoup hein vous
voyez qu'avant de lancer une balle à
cette vitesse là va falloir se lever tôt
pour la lune par exemple la vitesse de
libération est plus faible c'est
seulement 2,4 kilomètres par seconde
on se bat très surprenant puisqu'on sait
que l'attraction gravitationnelle à la
surface de la lune
elle est plus faible qu'à la surface de
la terre si maintenant on s'amuse à
faire le calcul pour le soleil on trouve
une valeur beaucoup plus élevé la
vitesse de libération elle est de 6 117
km par seconde
ça fait plus de deux millions de
kilomètres heure maintenant imaginez une
planète qui aurait la masse du soleil
mais qui ne ferait qu'un km de rayon
pourquoi pas après tout hein
si on s'amuse à calculer la vitesse de
libération à la surface de cette planète
on trouve 5 115 mille kilomètres par
seconde
voyez ce qui cloche ouais c'est plus que
la vitesse de la lumière
et on sait depuis einstein que rien ne
peut aller plus vite que la lumière
ça veut dire que si vous êtes à la
surface de cette hypothétique planète
jamais vous ne pourrez vous en échappée
est ce qu'on a là c'est une des
définitions possible d'un trou noir
un trou noir c'est un as dont la vitesse
de libération est plus grande que la
vitesse de la lumière
de sorte que rien ne peut s'en échapper
heureusement pour nous cette situation
n'est quand même pas très courante 1
vous voyez que la vitesse de libération
elle est d'autant plus importante que la
masse est importante et que le rayon est
petit donc elle correspond à des astres
qui sont extrêmement dense bien plus
dense que les planètes les étoiles
normal mais on pense que cette situation
peut quand même se produire pour
certaines étoiles à la fin de leur vie
faut savoir que quand une étoile a fini
d'épuiser tous le combustible nucléaire
qui lui permet de briller elle commence
à s'effondrer sur elle-même et donc elle
devient de plus en plus dense et sous
l'effet de l'attraction gravitationnelle
elle se densifie elle se densifie et
elle peut finir suffisamment dense pour
former un trou noir
c'est ce qu'on appelle les trous noirs
stellaires alors il faut savoir que
c'est pas le seul scénario possible pour
la fin de vie des étoiles mais on pense
que c'est ce qui se produit pour les
étoiles dont la masse dépasse plusieurs
fois la masse du soleil
et d'ailleurs si le destin des étoiles
vous intéresse je vous recommande
d'aller voir les vidéos de la chaîne le
sound of wonder qui a déjà parlé
notamment de la mort du soleil et des
supernova
il ya un point qui est vraiment très
important à comprendre pour bien
percevoir le côté maléfique des trous
noirs c'est qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'être à la surface de l'astre pour se
retrouver piégé il faut savoir que le
concept de vitesse de libération
il s'applique pas seulement quand vous
êtes à la surface mais il s'applique
aussi à proximité de l'astre on peut
reprendre notre calcul de tout à l'heure
avec une planète qu'à un rayon air et
une masse n imaginons qu'au lieu d'être
à la surface vous soyez à une distance d
du centre de la planète
eh ben on peut refaire exactement le
même calcul que tout à l'heure
sauf que cette fois dans l'énergie
gravitationnelle qu'il faudra vaincre
air sera remplacé par des et vous voyez
que la vitesse de libération deviendra
racines de de gm sur b tout à l'heure on
a vu que la vitesse de libération à la
surface de la terre c'était 11
kilomètres par seconde
et ben si je me place à 25000 km en
orbite au dessus de la surface
elle ne sera plus que d'environ 5 km par
seconde
on peut voir que la vitesse de
libération quand on a une certaine
distance de l'astre elle sera toujours
inférieure à ce qu'elle est quand on est
à la surface mais on peut imaginer que
si un astre est suffisamment dense et
qu'on n'est pas très loin même si on
n'est pas à la surface la vitesse de
libération puisse être plus grande que
la vitesse de la lumière et donc on
pourrait quand même se retrouver piégé
alors on peut créer une condition pour
savoir si on va être piégés ou pas si on
a un astre de masse m
la vitesse de libération elle sera
supérieure à la vitesse de la lumière
dès qu'on se trouve à une distance plus
petit qu'une valeur critique qui vaut de
gm sur ses cartes en gros si vous avez
un astre de masse m et que vous êtes à
une distance inférieure à cette distance
critique de lui eh ben vous êtes cuit et
en fait ça c'est vrai même si le rayons
de l'astre est bien plus petit que la
distance à laquelle vous vous trouvez
donc voyez que ce qui compte dans cette
affaire c'est pas tellement le rayon
physique de l'astre c'est plutôt cette
distance critique en dessous de laquelle
on est sûr d'être piégés cette distance
critique
on l'appelle le rayon de schwarzschild
de l'astre c'est en hommage au
mathématicien qui le premier a résolu
les équations de la relativité générale
dans le cas d'un corps ferrique dès
qu'un astre à un rayon physique qui est
plus petit que le rayon de schwarzschild
vous avez un trou noir est donc si vous
êtes à une distance inférieure à ce
rayon de sportive même si vous n'êtes
pas sur l'astre et ben vous êtes piégés
ce rayon de shark shield il délimite
donc une surface qu'on appelle l'horizon
du trou noir
c'est une frontière immatériel qui
marque le point de non retour
alors j'insiste sur le fait que cette
frontière et les immatériels parce que
au niveau de l'horizon du trou noir
il n'y a rien de spécial c'est juste la
limite de la zone en dessous de laquelle
vous êtes pluie
tout ça c'est très bien mais ça reste de
la théorie d'autant plus que si rien ne
s'échappe d'un trou noir comment on fait
pour les observer alors les trous noirs
stellaires ce qui résulte de
l'effondrement d'une étoile
on en a jamais observée avec une absolue
certitude on a un certain nombre de très
bons candidats dont on voit pas très
bien ce que ça pourrait être d'autre que
des trous noirs mais il subsiste quand
même encore un petit doute par contre il
ya une autre catégorie de trou noir dont
j'ai pas entendre parler et pour
lesquelles on est beaucoup plus
confiance c'est ce qu'on appelle lé trou
noir galactique
les trous noirs galactics des trous
noirs géants dont on pense qu'ils se
trouvent au centre d'à peu près toutes
les galaxies et notamment de la nôtre la
voie lactée
si vous voulez contempler un trou noir
ou tout du moins regardée dans sa
direction
vous pouvez les soirs d'été vous tourner
vers le sud et regardez la trace de la
voie lactée à proximité de la
constellation du sagittaire
alors c'est une constellation qui est
bien connue des astronomes amateurs
parce que ces étoiles principales
dessine une sorte de théières stylisé et
ben légèrement au-dessus du bec de la
théière c'est la direction du centre de
la voie lactée et c'est là qu'on trouve
un trou noir gigantesque qu'on appelle
sagittarius à étoiles et dont on pense
qu'ils fais environ 4 millions de fois
la masse du soleil
alors là vous allez me dire comment on
est sûr qu'il ya un trou noir attendre
là puisqu'on veut pas le voir
directement
alors c'est vrai qu'on peut pas voir
directement le trou noir lui-même mais
il ya deux choses qu'on peut observer la
première c'est la matière qui est autour
du trou noir et qui en train de tomber
vers le trou noir sont encore avoir
passé le point de non retour
cette matière elle est très fortement
accéléré et ça lui fait émettre des
rayonnements électromagnétiques qu'on
capte en provenance de cette direction
du ciel l'autre chose qu'on peut
observer c'est la trajectoire des toiles
qui sont très proches du trou noir et
qui tourne autour
récemment il ya des astronomes qui ont
analysé la trajectoire de ces étoiles et
ça leur a permis de calculer la masse du
trou noir
et d'estimer sa taille maintenant qu'on
a vu ce que c'est qu'un trou noir et
qu'on sait qu'ils existent
on peut se demander qu'est ce qui se
passe si jamais on en croise à bien si
vous croisez un trou noir et que vous
commencez à tomber vers lui ça va pas
être très très mouvementée en fait vous
allez tomber en chute libre mais comme
il n'y a pas d'air pour faire des
frottements ça va être très différent
d'une chute libre quand on tombe d'un
avion par exemple
en fait vous allez tomber et avoir
simplement la sensation d'être en totale
apesanteur ça va être plutôt sympa il ya
juste un problème dans cette histoire
c'est que si vous tombez par exemple les
pieds devant vos pieds vont être
légèrement plus proche du trou noir que
votre tête et donc il
subir une attraction gravitationnelle
qui va être un chouia plus importante
que celle suivie par votre tête
et le problème c'est qu'à force de
tomber ce chouïa il va devenir de plus
en plus gros et il va commencer à vous
étirer ce phénomène d'étirements c'est
ce qu'on appelle la force de marais
alors il n'est pas du tout spécifique
des trous noirs et c'est justement lui
qui explique le phénomène des marées sur
terre quand la lune et d'un certain côté
de la planète
elle va attirer un petit peu plus l'eau
qui est proche d'elle que l'eau qui est
loin d'elle et donc elle va déformer la
surface des océans et ça va causer des
marées hautes à certains endroits et des
marées basses à d'autres endroits
et vous quand vous allez tomber vers le
trou noir et bien ces forces de marée
elles vont commencer à vous étirez vous
étirez vous attirer jusqu'à vous
écartelée c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois
la spaghetti fication contrairement à
une idée répandue le fait de se faire
style et eefje a absolument rien à voir
avec le fait de franchir l'horizon du
trou noir à spaghetti fication elle peut
avoir lieu bien avant ou bien après
l'horizon d'ailleurs quand vous allez
passer l'horizon du trou noir
il va rien se produire deux spéciales
vous allez même pas de rendre compte
par contre si vous avez laissé un pote
en orbite un peu plus loin
lui il va avoir des drôles de trucs
quand vous tombez vers le trou noir
votre copain et bien il peut vous voir
tomber parce qu'il ya des rayons
lumineux que vous émettez et qui
parviennent jusqu'à lui et plus vous
approchez du trou noir plus les rayons
lumineux que vous émettez vont mettre du
temps à lui parvenir et donc lui il vous
fera tomber de plus en plus lentement et
en fait de son point de vue à lui votre
chute va tellement de plus en plus se
ralentir qui pourra vous regarder tomber
jusqu'à la fin des temps en fait il vous
verra vous rapprocher de plus en plus de
l'horizon mais il ne pourra jamais vous
voir le franchir ça c'était pour votre
pote qui est resté loin du trou noir et
qu'un train de regarder par contre vous
une fois que vous avez franchi l'horizon
ça va commencer à devenir beaucoup moins
cool ont déjà vous allez tomber de plus
en plus vite les forces de spaghettis
fication voit de plus en plus importante
et vraisemblablement vous allez me faire
écartelée imaginons quand même que vous
arriviez à survivre vous allez découvrir
que la structure de l'espace temps a
complètement changé
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
difficile à décrire sans vraiment
regarder les équations mais il ya quand
même une manière de le comprendre
vous avez pour nous sur terre on dit que
le temps s'écoule c'est à dire que le
temps passe et on peut absolument rien y
faire on veut pas décidé de rester à un
moment fixe du temps par contre pour
l'espace c'est beaucoup plus simple si
je veux rester dans une position fixe de
l'espace personne n'empêche est bien de
l'autre côté du rhône
ar c'est impossible de rester à une
position fixe de l'espace l'espace
s'écoule un peu de la même manière que
le temps s'écoule pour nous ça veut dire
que quoi que vous fassiez vous tombez
emule tab le mans vers le centre du trou
noir
si vous êtes tombé dans le trou noir en
étant équipé d'un jetpack ou alors à
bord d'une fusée qu'un moteur vous allez
peut-être tenter de vous en servir pour
essayer de ralentir un peu votre chute
en fait c'est une mauvaise idée parce
qu'on peut montrer que si jamais vous
essayez de vous débattre comme ça le
temps qui vous sépare du centre du trou
noir va se raccourcir si vous voulez que
le temps de votre chute vers le centre
du trou noir prennent le plus de temps
possible en fait la meilleure chose à
faire c'est de ne rien faire il faut se
laisser tomber en chute libre
une fois au centre du trou noir il faut
avouer qu'on sait pas très bien ce qui
se passe alors la théorie de la
relativité générale d'einstein nous dit
qu'au centre du trou noir
il ya un point où la densité et la
courbure de l'espace temps deviennent
infini ce qu'on appelle une singularité
sauf qu'en pratique on se douche qu au
voisinage de cette singularité la
théorie de la relativité générale toute
seule elle ne marche plus il faut
notamment prendre en compte des effets
de mécanique quantique et pour faire ça
correctement il faut qu'on dispose d'une
théorie qui unifie mécanique quantique
et relativité générale
aujourd'hui on a pas de terreau et comme
ça mais je vous en ai déjà parlé il ya
plusieurs tentatives il y en a une qui
est la théorie des cordes sur laquelle
j'avais fait une vidéo
et il y en a une autre qui est la
gravité quantique à boucles dont je vous
parlerai bientôt mais il faut avouer que
à l'heure actuelle aucune de ces deux
théories ne donne une réponse vraiment
très très satisfaisante pour savoir ce
qui se passe au voisinage de la
singularité est à l'heure actuelle les
trous noirs n'ont pas encore livré tous
leurs mystères voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui alors comme d'habitude j'ai
écrit un petit billet qui accompagne
cette vidéo et qui précise une chose ou
deux notamment il faut savoir que
l'argument que je vous ai donné pour
justifier l'existence des trous noirs
celui basé sur la vitesse de libération
en fait il est pas correct c'est un
argument qu'on appelle avec les mains
mais pour vraiment démontré que les
trous noirs existent il faut faire les
équations de la relativité générale ne
peut pas s'en sortir autrement si vous
voulez comprendre où est la faille dans
cet argument et comprendre un peu
pourquoi la relativité générale explique
l'existence des trous noirs vous pouvez
aller lire ce biais un autre biais que
j'ai écrit il ya quelques temps et qui
peut vous intéresser
se demande si on peut créer des micro
trous noirs dans le lhc vous savez
l'accélérateur de particules du service
alors à priori il ya peu de chances mais
il ya quand même une certaine
lyon de la théorie des cordes qui prédit
que peut-être au lhc on pourrait créer
des micro trous noirs
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo comme
d'habitude si elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à la partager pour m'aider à faire
connaître la chaîne vous pouvez vous
abonner vous pouvez me retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux facebook twitter
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me
soutenir sur tipi merci beaucoup à tous
les types heures foot soutiennent et
vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon
job sur ce étonnant
merci et à bientôt